good morning reg how are you good
morning Theodor last week you posed the
question to me who was the better team
in LA yep and I'm going to stay with my
pic and saying I will take the best
player on either team obviously in
LeBron James and the Lakers but I'm here
to say not by a lot because the Clippers
are balling because it's almost like
this is Christmastime Rudolph the Red
Nosed Reindeer is at the island of
misfit toys we all seen that that's what
the Clippers are they have a bunch of
guys that other organizations did not
want and Doc Rivers has found a home for
them and they play hard they play
together and you've got a bonafide
closer agha in the fourth quarter that
you can count on and sweet Lou Williams
so though I'm gonna go with LeBron James
and the Lakers because he's the best
player and I think he can make more
happen it's not by a lot that the Lakers
are the best team in Los Angeles okay if
there was a seven-game series between
the Lakers and the Clippers who do you
have who has home court advantage
between the Lakers and the Clippers if
it's right now the Clippers having a
home court advantage I mean that is a
really tough call I mean I still would
have to err on the side of the Brawn
James because we've seen it I've seen it
I mean generational player I would still
side with LeBron but it could go either
way and the growth of Tobias Harris
montrezl Harold has been fantastic for
Doc Rivers Gallinari has found his game
again after the knee injury they've got
a bunch of pieces the question I have
for the Clippers going forward is can
they sustain this you know it's we're
only a quarter pole of the season we're
20 games in and they've looked great can
they sustain that through the midway
point
can they sustain this you know the rest
of the way I don't know but what I've
seen through 20 games is I like their
character and I like the way they play
you got the Clippers in the Kings
tomorrow night at 10:30 Eastern on TNT
I like the Kings reg I said that I think
Darren has really had a big turnaround
from last year I think he's playing
great so you know I could turn out to be
an entertaining game where you probably
didn't think it was gonna be when the
season started you know I talked about
the Clippers and their character I'm
playing hard you could put the same
there's been three surprises to me in
the league this year one of them being
the Clippers the Memphis Grizzlies
they're back to that pounding grind type
game and they are successful with it and
the Sacramento Kings you know four or
five days ago they should have beaten
that Golden State Warriors team in
Golden State I think they just fell
apart at the end of the game and Katie
and clay you know rose to the occasion
but the Kings they have a great young
nucleus you talked about the Aaron Fox
Bagley Bogdanovich these guys buddy
hield who has found a home coming from
New Orleans great young players they
play hard it's just a matter of them
figuring it out and before the Kings
would lose close wings they're finding
ways to win close games now and to me
you got to give the March of that
coaching staff but you're right these
are two surprise teams that are going at
it tomorrow and the Kings aren't the
same Kings that we've seen the last few
years that they would just kind of roll
over and play hard for a quarter or a
half and you know it'd be a 15 20 point
blowout the Aaron Fox is he is a
superstar in the making he's not there
yet but he is a superstar in the making
yeah he's a lot of fun I like his
turnaround this year we were talking
about best backcourts we got on this
topic James Harden went for 54 the other
night so the back
combined for 90 points but Kobe and
smush Parker have the most combined
points in a game that's when ever when a
koblan for 81 who's the best back well
hello what is this go for that night I
think 12 or 13 so they combined 494
Kobayashi had 81 so but Eric Gordon and
Harden combined 490 that's the second
highest point total for a backcourt in a
game best backcourt you think of all
time is who I would probably go with
well you want to assume it's going to be
Michael and whomever or you could throw
magic and Byron Scott I think I got it I
got one for oh here we go one Isaiah and
Joe Dumars yeah that was the one I had
yeah Isaiah and Joe I would probably go
with because both could kill you in a
number of ways I'm not high
pick-and-roll and let's not forget Joe
Dumars one of the best you know before
we started talking about two-way players
Joe Dumars was the definition of that
because not only could he get you twenty
five thirty at one end he was gonna lock
you down at the other who else would be
in there for greatest backcourts Earl
Monroe and Walt Frazier in New York yeah
yeah when they played together Goodrich
and West were really good great scorers
Jerry of course the great all-around
player trying to think Stefan clay are
they the best backcourt of all time
well no not of all time but they're
certainly in the conversation they're
the best best backcourt in today's game
obviously so certainly I would put them
in the top three or four yeah I would
definitely put and you guys look at the
body of work three championships
together
yeah clay and stuff are definitely there
Parker and Ginobili
but Ginobili wasn't a starter so it's
hard to put them in that category so no
I would say now okay I'm trying to think
who else might be in there Reggie Miller
and Mark Jackson all right I know
Monica's probably listening so where is
Mark aha is marking the whole thing he
should be absolutely you don't become
the third or fourth time all timing
assist and not be standing on a podium
somewhere thanking people yeah but I'm
close to this situation I lived you know
obviously everything he's done I've
lived through it so yeah he he's a
hall-of-famer in my book you know what I
would think that if I'm gonna make a
comparison mark Jackson's playing career
is like Frank Gore the running back yeah
really good not the best put up some
great numbers has a jump from team to
team yeah you know it just wasn't with
one team the body of work New York
Denver obviously the Clippers Indiana
and I body of work for Marcus bear and
Tom Chambers dunked on Frank Gore as
well do you weren't there that that was
will no he was with New York there okay
and we still clown them today with that
bad or wasn't with the Clippers it was
one of the two but that's by far
probably one of the most realistic is
that's one of those moments you can't
erase that because it was an open court
you know it was like he went baseline
and there's a lot of traffic in the lane
that was a fast break and you just so
happened to be caught on the island by
yourself
MJ no no that you know why this stands
out because it wasn't like no it was a
white yeah that's true if there was
Shawn Kemp then it wouldn't stand out
the way it did because it's Tom Chambers
but because it's Tom Chambers Tom
Chambers had up
yeah now even serious up Amos a great
music great player you never got
posterized like that did you not like
that everyone has been dunked on in them
I know but not like that like you didn't
have like that no that is a signed
poster that keeps your name around
forever because you played that
highlight all the time but if you're Tom
Jackson could you ask Mark Jackson to
sign the poster absolutely
I was absolutely hey I'm doing a signing
up in Seattle and I need like 200 poster
sign oh yeah if I pay you yeah okay okay
I understand
I was also there's a couple other things
here with marquel folds you know the
Sixers are gonna move on from him I
still want to know I don't they use
healthy I don't think the shoulders ever
been healthy and now if you're gonna try
to trade him like what can you get from
marquel folds nothing and where would be
a good place for him to maybe try to
start over I'm thinking it would have to
be a young team that's on the rise that
probably doesn't have playoff
aspirations because you're not going to
get anything in return for the overall
number one payment see it you're just
not gonna get anything and no one's
gonna want to give up any valued assets
knowing that the history of the shoulder
or not knowing what is wrong with the
shoulder that's the problem is no one
can really definitively say this is
wrong with him you know some people have
said that yet you know it's head games
now no one knows is there an injury
did something happen before no one knows
so why would a organization want to give
up at number one or a valued asset for
an unproven commodity so a young team in
Brooklyn you know Orlando Phoenix
Orlando Phoenix you know yeah teams like
that that have young players that are on
the rise you know DeAndre Aiden and
Booker Devin Booker possibly in Phoenix
you know there's not a lot of
expectations out there but I feel for
the kid
because we've called I called a couple
of his games early when he was in the
starting lineup / JJ reddick and in Dan
you could just see in his eyes something
wasn't right
something wasn't clicking and I tell you
know I said on air don't focus on your
shot or your shooting
trying to do the other things because
Philadelphia is a hard place to play and
if you're gonna mope about your shooting
and things that aren't going wrong the
Philadelphia faithful will let you know
do the little things dive on the floor
loose falls going for every rebound to
be a defensive stopper do the little
things that are gonna make the faithful
Philadelphia fans get behind you but he
was kind of going through the motions
and just not all there and you know I
feel for the kid because to be the
overlooked they had options I mean look
at Jason Tatum he's turned out to be a
superstar in Philadelphia they had
options and they chose wrong here's the
stat I don't know how troubling you
think this is Trey young is shooting 24%
from three-point range so far this this
season that's the lowest mark through 21
career games in the last 35 years second
lowest is Lonzo ball who shot 25.7%
through 21 games last season I'm more
shocked at very young than I am along
the wall I wasn't shocked last year by
the struggles of Lonzo I didn't think
Trey would struggle this much and would
you say 24 percent yeah I better shooter
than that but hey the defense is a lot
better better than the big 12 don't you
think well I think if you had the
football defenses guarding him then in
the barrel that would help very true
that would that would that would help a
lot
have you watched Duke basketball much I
have did you watch him last night I did
I'm curious about them and a half-court
offense of like a tight game half-court
offense you know the difference that you
that we saw that in Hawaii yeah we saw
that
and I'm sure come a CC play when they're
going against Virginia Tech in Carolina
and NC State and things like that where
every game obviously comes down to a
half-court
we'll see what these young guys are made
of unbelievably talented Coach K once
again is going to have his hands full
and being able to distribute the wealth
but they play hard and they play
together but you're right
come ACC time in come tournament time
when the game slows down and it's not a
track meet where you know it's off to
the races can you make basketball plays
I know RJ Barrett you know camreta Shu
has struggled with this shot and Zion
Williams I mean he was 11 for 15 in all
eleven were dunks basically they were
all in the paint so when you start to
play the better teams with better
coaching and better players and teams
start to you know watch film and take
away your first two or three moves
what's your counter and I think that's
what we'll see is this young Duke team
kind of grows up in front of us but
they're fun to watch don't get me wrong
and I think they are the team to beat
but it's gonna be curious
once the reel as I call them the real
games really start come ACC tournament
time and one final thing and I wasn't
gonna call you out on this but the
Clippers Lakers home court advantage
seven-game series who's gonna play at
home on their side no not the crowd okay
we're gonna have the theater lighting
which the Lakers have like the baskets
were guarding that theater lighting
which is really cool or who has all the
lights on like the Clippers right Lakers
have that cool Broadway theater lighting
its ambiance you know the court is the
only thing lit and it's also the
difference could be theater
lighting it could be okay I could be and
that's why you do this for a living
theater lighting oh yes have fun
tell the boys tell car Kevin and Ali we
said hello and Clippers Kings tomorrow
night 10:30 Eastern on TNT thanks reg as
usual stepping up for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]